de quelles fleurs français le tarn est
il un afflux re vous allez devoir aller
dans le bac piocher une question du bac
si vous répondez bien mélanie repartira
avec un magnifique cadeau au jour pour
mélanie notre téléspectatrices je vais
prendre pour ce premier bac pour aller
chercher le premier papier vallée l'ebbe
dhr et non oui je n'ai pas le temps d'y
attaque beau parce que coach bien vite
et alors mais c'était chroniqueur fait
les souffrir
on joue pour mélanie d'accord d'aller
pas si vous devez piocher une question
du bac et ensuite y répondre d'accord on
a trois questions allez-y mais arrêtez
de regarder oui le metella m'arrêter là
vincent bragny monde a dit on y va on
s'en fout on y monte son nom mais sa
mort saint
mais d'en savoir pas du tout a laissé
les arrête pas là mais j'arrive pas
choquer mais normale et il ya plein de
questions à l'aise il faut que c'est
l'accession et réponses aux mélanie on
va tous leurs très bons cadeaux à
mélanie
[Musique]
c'est de faire tout le monde
quel était le prénom du philosophe
allemand nietzsche chaque fois qu'ils
sont nombreux
alors je vous donne 3 points 3
possibilités el mout jean rachid où
friedrich au cours des mois précédents
on ne fait pas un frigidaire
je sens que ça bouge à des pratiques que
ça on a un spécialiste des insectes ici
c'est jeff taffe djafour lui prendre un
truc comme ça oui mais tel n'a peur de
rien il ya des crises a dit legging la
des crocodiles chez lui je peux pas je
te jure je peux pas aller peut pas le
faire je ne peux pas mais là il me
tutoie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oh
alors la merde de cas je sais pas ça de
quel flop français le tarn est il un
affluent de quelques clubs français
oui le tarn étiez un afflux à ça à vous
de répondre bah oui au département
département le terminal la garonne
dacquois lagarde le la garonne ne
gardent beaucoup du tube fait rentrer la
garonne fouet la garantie liant la
garonne
c'est une bonne réponse
[Applaudissements]
m
non
kader de mathieu fais pas ta frigide
[Applaudissements]
et
non je crois pas que ce soit des
services au sol je regardais non j'ai
pas des serpents écoutez ça ressemble à
des serpents
ça ressemble
oui c'est vrai ça ressemble à du service
après tout c'est le suédois qua non non
non humains jeu une fois surtout fait
alors vous êtes vous savez quoi je vais
faire quelque chose que je ne fais
jamais je vais prendre quelqu'un du
public pour vos places et moi pour nous
entendre aux grandes gueules à l aca
mercader nico tu vas devoir jouer pour
mel mélanique est une collègue à toi
parce qu'elle est aussi italienne avait
vite à liège
si ça tu vas devoir piocher une question
du bac et y répondre tu es le bac
oui tu me manques non le sens j'ai loupé
pour ça non pas du tout pas dit mon
chien voilà la mets ta main
t'as jamais touché de chapeau non c'est
rien ça tu veux curé d'alors
non ça c'est pas une tête ça c'est un
fait vaval à balla balla bâillonnera
inverse de son la loi que vanguard bien
vers l'eau ici on était plus facile je
suis là je me sois là voilà celui-là
voila voila c'est gentillet
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous avez de quoi at en décider j'ai eu
de la peau de serpent la demande de la
famille d'isabelle morini bosc
[Musique]